pretty sure I have the worst comment
section of all time it's not like oh
they are so toxic oh they're so hateful
oh they're so mean no they're just
terrible it's basically people trying to
get uploaded by making the same comment
as everyone else
the game is blocked in your country me
sad noises me sad noises me sad noises
me sad noises me sad noises me sad
noises stop slip that slipped a better
day no sweet every minute a door so go
visit that a time to review let's see
what epic memes you guys are posted this
week the redesigned sonic looks so much
better I know one person that is gonna
be very happy
everyone say thank you to the nice
artists that listen to criticism and fix
their mistakes I still can't believe
y'all cyber pulled in an entire studio
you know now I'm kind of like oh I wish
you didn't change it imagine all the
epic memes imagine the world is still
images we could have gotten it would
have been awesome
Felix downloading my meme with over 60
I'll do whatever it takes I don't care I
just got out of an abusive marriage and
had to go through two surgeries thank
you for giving me a reason to smile in
these hard times ah that's nice are you
trying to stay honest at me what's
happening here what are you doing don't
do that don't that'll stop me I'm glad
me obviously making fart noises is
Jeremy Uwe here's one for you bruh
[Music]
moving on youtuber hits hunter cave
subscribers honey Skillshare nord BPM
and that was to introduce ourselves hey
skills share what are you doing where's
my sponsor come on come on skills [ __ ]
emojis bad will you press the button you
make $1,000,000 per month but you can't
use emojis ever again who craves these I
need to make another one of these
because I have the best morals of all
time and it's so painfully obvious you
guys are a bunch of fools it's your
opportunity Felix terraria is getting
its final update
after eight years of success yeah I know
I've been getting a lot of comments to
play Terraria maybe I will because the
mine crowd episodes is becoming very
ungrateful okay I buy so much time and
everyone it's a planet nobody's waiting
to host me movie okay cool so no one
epic team behind the viral okay boomer
merch rejects 1.7 million offer by
replying okay boomer
that is the cringes thing I have ever
heard is that the personal or what is
this team behind a viral merch cool so
you put okay boomer as a txt viral March
everyone I never heard of it but viral
merch cool epic cringe that's a Boomer
from from Zoomer
I'll cringe at that oh god I need to
personally stop him how many is that
that's more than I have oh god stop him
imagine being this freaky shitty I've
seen this dog thrilled to see owners ID
shelter but they're there to adopt
different done thanks critique Sonic's
design son hahaha that's good good meme
well done well done
Jake Pole cries backstage after Logan /
loses - ksi I know so great
beautify uploads a Minecraft video and
the boohoo award goes to Jake ball
everybody well I was so confused was
Justin Bieber action at the fight I
thought it was like a look-alike that
was actually just I'm so confused I
guess I forget he's like a kin he
probably watches YouTube Justin Bieber
put a low gang epic all hail Lord joints
Scoob can't wait to see their origin
story behind Shaggy's power oh I get it
that's funny
a friend pointed out to me that
scooby-doo clearly are a bunch of
stoners they always stay back when
everyone else goes to find the whatever
they have to find in the creepy area and
then they get the munchies and that's
when they go in the house my brain just
like exploded when I found that out
paramount fixes Sonic cast Keanu Reeves
Oliver edit I think we're gonna be
friends special friends what about me
huh where's my movie part huh I can act
that's me being sad I got a whole wide
range of emotions six cubed
remove remove the editing is what you're
trying to type you dumbass are you a
writer you can't get the title rank for
thousand kilo plastic from C in Andhra
Pradesh that's awesome good job you can
also use that water gun name against the
Sun to that but it's still a good effort
okay shout out to my boy Steve who stood
in front of a green screen for years
running in place and talking to
invisible objects and animals so kids
like me could have entertaining
educational television I didn't watch
this what is this
get this away from me god damn it Fitz
turns 30
also boots I like of people legit word
about my eyesight he's gonna go Floyd
I've always had bad vision redesign
sonic Keanu Reeves in sponge Keanu
Reese's in the Spongebob Bobby that's
awesome I will watch Spongebob movie now
first guy that paid 399 for a chair must
have been like I guess they all right
you know I'm not gonna fight this
anymore this meme gets a pass all right
you get to pay whoa here's a full scale
PewDiePie figurine redline render that
is sick I love the jacket that's so cool
that insane well done I love that you
can also buy this figurine with
detachable headphones okay link
description I think is the last chance
to order now this meme I think I forgot
something me if you forgot then it
wasn't important this meme yeah you're
right oh god what was it but what's it
what if we kissed at the pity price good
name good name when you see a funny meme
and notice that it has 68 uploads this
is me after no November am i right
gamers Keanu Reeves in the Spongebob
movie sonic having a redesign scooby-doo
reference yeah oh yeah they reference
IKEA it did after all how dare they by
the way how dare they steal my culture
like that we don't have any culture in
Sweden except IKEA and meatballs and if
anyone touches those can't believe
Target already has Christmas decorations
out I'm so glad that this meme got so
popular when my Photoshop meme it's
coming up in another episode didn't get
any traction it's a future meme you
understand later oh my god Nate Eric's
tagged an insanely good artist it's
always so sweet to see what they come up
with gout adorable Swedish weapon be
like rubberband men again what bang ding
seriously I want it all the effort to
reload that thing my god
Logan poll after snoozing three times
half my respiratory organs were
destroyed hence me losing the fight or
was it because I lost two points I can't
remember there was many reasons wet get
that thing out of my face
Petey pyres Bizarre Adventure chomp
chomp oho Jotaro what girls watch on
YouTube simple glam makeup tutorial but
boys watch on YouTube Keanu Reaves
vs. will do the end words apocalypse oh
my god can you imagine if they all said
it the amount of destruction power in
such a small entity at least like at
least you can respect that
alright whatever you think about it at
least respect the power the power that
comes with it just like woody in Toy
Story said with great power great
sources of response coincidence I think
not alright I'll stop wearing the
glasses fine I don't care
they put Keanu Reeves in spongebob movie
kids calling him John wick from
fortnight I can't believe they put John
wick in fortnight though like it's such
a violent film it's like they put John
wick and sponsor like it doesn't I don't
think it works like that but hey dog oh
yes wait wat I mean Felix video yay
and your meme got uploaded a a new frame
to it me rotates my phone by one degree
my phone oh which that took me well okay
epic oh my god that's a skin oh god stop
wait there's more
is he photoshopping them that's illegal
you can't Photoshop them it's not my
garbage but it is my planning oh yeah
there's like this Instagram hashtag I
don't know what it's called it's like
hashtag
trash cleanup or something where you
post before and they push after what you
cleaned up but unless you you're
planning to eat that garbage I mean
you're not really I'm just kidding all
right that's great that's a good it's
good movement everyone should do
something epic Wow he just sat there
well someone was cleaning the beach Wow
original content idea okay great
feeling stacking Kenny she challenged
himself to post five memes anonymously
in the subreddit and the one with the
most upload Vince okay I like that
that's a good idea that's a good idea I
might try that or may not how only post
it if I win speech pathologists teachers
our dog to use sound board and now it
communicates in sentences where are my
testicles summer where are all their
weekend Morty episodes is so good I
don't care if it became cringe it's
still a good show it's the leg less
PewDiePie joke still a thing legs I
finally made it
I guide others to treasure I cannot
present so much time on that video and
it did so she therapist the guy from the
math problem isn't real it can't hurt
you
the guy from math problem Oh God where
does it get them from does he live in
the factory or something everyone is
talking about how sonic epically
redesigned but these are unforgettable I
really hope they make in the movie like
an end credits scene or something a no
marsh to these legends you know what are
you watching
son a man who raped my main by calling
my PP Baker's mom why is he talking
about their baby you wouldn't get it
don't even ask mom cringe people large
by the way people large
Felix nightmares be like Jesus oh god
stop why would you do that I told my
teenage knees to get me a newspaper she
laughed at me and said Oh uncle you're
so old just use my phone so I slammed
her phone against the world to kill
spider challenging PD PI to a boxing
fight veggie did it huh he won't feed
you because he respect lemon that's true
do they'll still beat them up though
this comment is completely irrelevant
Netflix and chill Hulu and whoohoo watch
Mickey and break gay okay okay all right
side effects include death nausea
heartburn skin irritation people in the
commercial oh my god this is the best
product ever it's always weird I don't
think it's we're allowed to market those
kind of Medicine ads in in UK so
whenever we go to America and you watch
TV how many there are it's crazy oh my
god I feel so good and drinky fool it's
so good I might heart explode and their
code peach pie by the way if you don't
enter the computer pie I don't get paid
as much ok bees into the code oh my god
there it is again
upload that is brilliant well played
what a great mood that's so clever ha ha
ha
because that's what heroes do me Wow
so I used ready for the first time in an
upcoming video and I never understood
like how nice it is to get upvotes now I
get it like I get it I get your norm a
struggle you know you're trying to get
uploads and stuff and like why are
people downloading my stuff to like
that's just mean why would you do that I
can see like down votes on my stuff I
don't like it stop downloading me ok I
worked at McDonald's for two and a half
years and I put 11 nuggets in almost
every 10 piece of me careful he's a hero
Cody bundle chuck if I got it 11 nuggets
I know it's something would be wrong
with it this post that's a tiny peepee
nothing gets through this armor what
about our oxygen listen here you little
[ __ ]
Wow tiny peepee boomers when they watch
TV for five hours straight boomers when
they see someone on their phone for five
minutes
what look up look up hello I'm here okay
that's all I wanted to do
boomers invented phones and video games
boomers continue screaming oh my god
yeah you're right new research says
short people are angrier and more
violent than tall people delete this
small people downloaded with your
current account balance which Apple
product can you buy Apple I mean
well played wait there's still come on
guys check out team trees there's still
4,500,000 treats if it costs $1 to plant
one tree surely it's cheaper if we
manage to raise a lot of money right or
do they count that if they find 20
million trees it will cost $1 right do
you understand what I'm saying supply
chain management you understand yeah I
just want to know how it works okay
or does it scale backwards where it's
more expensive I just want to know
because maybe technically we already
erased enough to plan 20 million trees
that's what I'm saying in 2015 a
Canadian man was arrested after tying
more than hundred balloons a garden
chair and flying over the city of
calgary that is such a mr. B's video
waiting to happen
good job don't give up etc subtitles
hundred Wow fansubs are the best the
silver snipers are a competitive gaming
team from Sweden between ages of 62 and
81 Dan that's awesome
can you imagine in the future
retirements gonna be the best
Pearce I didn't have many friends when I
was younger oh it appears and this is
the garbage bread it wasn't even my
friend it was my sister's friend okay oh
god I had no friends
[Laughter]
Millennials are killing the doorbell
industry by texting here okay boomer how
about just knocking in the door is that
harder herobrine the most strongest
entity in Minecraft Felix thinking he
can beat him in a fight hero Brian I'll
challenge you in boxing fight alright I
think it could be cool I'll do it I'll
do it I'll kill him
these knuckles
can destruction anyone anyone that
challenges me the earth is flat so if we
just flip it over it will be like the
cool side of the pillow and boom no more
global warming my god
these are the young minds of our
generation that will save all our future
problems thank you how do I buy a house
how do I get a job how do I pay taxes
schools yes isn't it weird like the
government who is in charge of schools
doesn't have anything about paying taxes
surely they would want that it's almost
like the government wants you to not pay
taxes so they can find you and pay you
more taxes am I right gamers all of our
employees try to stop me after I buy a 6
6 5 inch 4k Ultra HD TV for 1 0 a that
self-checkout we can't stop me why is
this meat funny it's not even funny
thank you guys for watching another
episode of smash like if you enjoyed
check out the merch and its really put
it makes links if you enjoy that game
and buy Hado hey hey and we're all
excited about the new game that's coming
out and I can't wait to play it it
starts with the letter P can you guess
what it is
here the pie pick selling of course what
you thought it was Pokemon dumbass you
stinky brainer
you